new faces old names
most of these politicians may be
campaigning to win a seat in lebanon's
parliament on sunday but their surnames
are anything but neo
first time candidate michelle moore is
one of the fresh faces seeking to be
elected but his family has been deeply
rooted in the country's politics for
decades
he is the son of former deputy prime
minister and defense minister elias
moore
his grandfather michel moore also served
as interior minister and his mother is
the daughter of a former president emil
lahood
if i'm privileged it doesn't mean i
don't know what's going around
going on around me
or
in this district
every day
i see people and i stay with people
that are suffering in this crisis
my family has been in this
political world for the past 50 years
therefore i don't think the
they call the level on the chair that
will reach
isn't the main goal
the main goal is that i think i can
better help the people i'm seeing them
every day
for many of lebanon's most powerful
families a seat in parliament is seen as
part of their inheritance
and many candidates are contesting seeds
held by one of their parents
lebanon's economy collapsed in 2019 and
that led to large-scale demonstrations
against the political elite ultimately
forcing the government to resign many
lebanese call this the october 17
revolution after this different
movements were born and many developed
into alternative political parties and
so-called
anti-establishment independence but many
waters question whether the new parties
can perform any better than the
political establishment they oppose
26 years old verina al-amil is one of
the youngest independent candidates
running for parliament but without the
backing of a powerful political family
she says accountability has been absent
from lebanese institutions for decades
i want accountability
now i think since the war started since
the 70s
the warlords became
became and became the ruling class
and i think those uh who were the cause
of the misery of the country they are
still running the country
and now we are in a crisis that they are
responsible of on sunday several seas in
lebanese parliament are expected to be
passed on from an old relative to a
younger member of the family as the
political class shows little sign of
fading
and many will be waiting to see whether
the newcomers succeed in bringing change
the sousader al jazeera beirut